Ok so i wanna do a video that covers oneof the
most common questions we get on thechannel
which is people saying "i'm in, i'mdown but
what can we do?" and the way i wantto
answer that is to basically talk about howi have
approached the question of "what should ido?"
so i became convinced that inequality was
basically the core economic problem when i
was a trader back in sort of 2010, 2011
2012, 2013 and i finally quit that job in 2014
basically thinking okay i have
to do something but what do i do?
so the very first thing i did was i basically
wrote down i made a website which wrote down
really clearly how does inequality affect the
economy if anybody wants to read that website it's
still up it's wealtheconomics.org we've bought
the name garyseconomics.org i should really move it
to that but it's currently wealtheconomics.org
so i explained the theory and it took me like
a couple of months to write this website really
clearly and then i finished it and realised like
no one is ever going to see this
website because nobody knows who i am
so i thought okay basically at this point i'vegot 2
options which is try to get famous so people read
my website or go back to uni andconvince
academics so they can spread the message
and this might be a surprise to some people but
it was never originally my intention to become
famous so i decided to go back to university first
that's when i realised the guys at university are
just like out of the game they are not going to
fix this so i realised okay you're going to try
to build this message up yourself and that is
why for the last nearly two years i've been trying
to basically build a brand to spread this message
and my belief is if people understood how serious
this situation was, how bad the economy will become
if we don't fix inequality then it would be number
one priority for people when they went to the
voting booth and people would demand from their
politicians you have to fix this, this is like a
urgent disaster the reality of the situation
is if we don't fix wealth inequality
life is going to get significantly worse forpeople
in this country generation after generationafter
generation, you know the next generation will...
we're already seeing it now you know it's gonna
be a struggle just for a basic life for a lot ofpeople
and that will become more and more common
and it will become increasingly impossible to
get rich you know it will be very difficult even
to just get a basic level of comfort that's the
reality if we don't fix wealth inequality right
if people knew that they would stop it but i
think the number one problem at the moment is
people don't people don't realize that people are
not being told the truth about the economy people
are not being told look the economy is going to
get worse year after year that's the truth right
if people knew that they would stop it so what
i'm trying to do is make as many people as
possible aware and my hope initially and it
still is my hope is that people will see it
they'll jump on board and they'll amplify the
message so people watch these videos they'll
share it with their friends you know i mean they'll
share it with their family and increasingly people
start to realise look this is what's happening
and i always try and back it up with predictions
like at the beginning of Covid i saidlook this
will happen with Covid - the rich willget richer
house prices will go up, stock price will go
up, inequality will go up, inflation will go up
and hopefully people will see those things and
they'll realise that this guy Gary - he's right
and they'll see also things continuing to get
worse and worse and worse and they'll say we
need to support this guy basically i mean whatwill
happen for sure is if we don't fix wealthinequality
things will get worse that is what willhappen
and at the moment we're not heading towards
fixing wealth inequality so things are going to
get worse and that means people are going to get
angrier people are going to get more frustrated
with the status quo and people are going to be
looking for alternatives right and my idea now
is that this channel and these ideas become
an alternative and the way they will become an
alternative is by people supporting them by people
spreading the message so you know recently i've
been a bit more aggressive with saying look follow
the channel get your friends to follow the channel
spread the channel because the bigger my voice
gets the more influential these ideas become you
know i got invited to go to parliament this week
and they're just doing that because they want
to give a little like yeah we invited him at the
moment i'm not big enough to actually force them
to make a change but if we get bigger and bigger
and bigger and more people are listening to these
ideas we can get a point where they have to listen
and we can get a point where we can make this
international you know and i know that's ambitious
but the problem is massive so we have
to be ambitious you know what i mean
so when people say what can i do
we have to build a movement we have to build a
movement and you know it might sound selfish me
saying you need to support this channel you need
to support my socials you need to share my videos
but who else is doing this you know if thereare
other people out there doing this get intouch
with me and there are some people you know i
support Patriotic Millionaires i support Tax Justice
UK but the truth is nobody is spreading this
message on a big enough scale so i'm trying to
do it so the number one you know i always bring it
down to these three things first of all understand
the number one idea of this channel is to help
ordinary people understand what's happening
i think nobody's out there making economics
accessible and easy to understand and explain
what's happening so these videos are here so
ordinary ordinary people can understand quite
simply wealth inequality is [ __ ] you and it's
[ __ ] the economy it's as simple as that and
if and that it's not going to get better unless
we fix it listen wealth inequality is a cancer
in this economy and if somebody's got cancer you
could do whatever you like around about it if you
don't fix the cancer that person will die and that
is what is going to happen in this economy if we
do not fix wealth inequality everything else will
gradually become unaffordable and you're seeing
it happening the nhs will become unaffordable
good quality education will become unaffordable
good quality housing unaffordable we will lose
all of the things that our great grandparents
worked and fought so hard for to make this country
a country in which ordinary people can have a good
quality of life we will lose those things if we
don't fix wealth inequality so how do we fix it?
look it's not going to be short and sharp it's not
going to be easy but it's possible listen i quit a
million-pound-a-year job to do this and i wouldn't
have done that if i thought it was impossible
i could be on a beach in the Philippines but
i'm here in London in the cold wearing acoat
because i think we can fix this i think we
can fix this but it's not going to be easy look
very rich people don't want this don't want things
to change because they're doing very well out of
this and they're on the newspapers you know what i
mean and they're in the radio stations and they're
going to go out and say oh no you shouldn't tax
the rich if you do it be an economic disaster
understand that's [ __ ] secondly they're going
to say oh but you can't tax them because they'll
leave understand that's [ __ ] you know and we
we've explained both of those things extensively
on this channel and we will explain them more
understand that we have to fix it if you want
to fix the economy and we can fix it if we agree
that this is the only thing we vote for it's the
only thing that we demand it's number one priority
um so that's what we have to do educate yourself
support this channel if you have ways that
you can support like get in touch what are
we looking for what are we looking
for Sim? people to help us grow it
people to do subtitles so we can make it
international yeah people who have basically
to help us grow the channel because we're getting
to the stage now there's a lot of good videoshere
and it needs to be bigger we're only going tochange
things if we make things bigger you know so
*we tried to approach like Russell Brand...* yeah listen
if you know Russell Brand if you know Martin Lewis
or if you know anyone with a big voice who can
help us amplify them put them in touch with us man
because look i'm out here i was one of the
best paid economists in the world i know
what's happening i called it from the start i know
what's happening i know how to fix it but i need
to get on the stage so i need people to help me
to do that basically um in the meantime we're
going to be out here on my balcony making videos
every week and out in the parks watch the videos
share the videos, subscribe, press that little
bell thing whatever it does apparently it's
good for the channel but help us grow man and
spread the message and you know you can talk to
your politicians but the main thing we need is
basically people to help us build the voice but
every single person watching can help by
subscribing and sharing with their friends man
and understanding what's happening and being
passionate and it's it's not even just about
me when you're talking to your friends and your
family about the economy say look i think the
problem is inequality of wealth and i'm
not just saying that there's this guy who
explains it very clearly - show them my website,
show them my videos like look it's ideas and
stories that change the world, things are going
to get really really really seriously bad here
seriously and that is [ __ ] up but it's also an
opportunity to change things listen the last thing
that really really significantly improved quality
of life in this country and all over the west was
the second world war because things were so [ __
] up that people said no we're not going to accept
it we demand change and they got change they
got affordable housing good quality healthcare
good quality education for all the people in this
country even the poorest people in this country
and it was the second world war that achieved
that because when times are really really bad
that's an opportunity to bring people together i
mean have an opportunity like that now and that's
what i'm trying to do here so i would encourage
anybody support the channel support anyone else
you know who's campaigning for inequality bring
people in and help grow this voice and that
hopefully is how we achieve change and i'm
not saying it's going to work i'm not saying
we're definitely going to win but if we
lose it's a big problem so we have to try
so yeah please support us keep
watching keep sharing thank you